hi there Steve Kaufman here again today
I want to talk about the age we live in
the which I would call the digital age
and the opportunities for language
learning and I'll touch on some things
that I've spoken about before and I'll
also sneak in a few pet peeves now my
last video which was a sort of an
unscheduled video where I talked about
you know the Canadian government wasting
money on this futile expenditure of five
hundred million dollars a year to
promote bilingualism when really
bilingualism is is more a matter of
individual motivation than anything the
government can resolve by throwing money
at it of course the government is mostly
looking after what they consider to be
their stakeholders which is various
constituencies that they cater to to
gain votes or support or whatever anyway
leaving that aside digital age you know
I am an optimist I think this is the
greatest age to be alive but you know
what it wouldn't matter when I was alive
I would consider it the greatest age to
be alive because we have no choice in
the matter
the alternative to being alive is
nothingness so you may as well take
advantage of what you have and look on
the bright side so I am NOT I have no
sympathy for all the pessimists who see
nothing but darkness and we're
destroying the planet Navas other stuff
we're not destroying a planet there are
issues which we should deal with but
they were not destroying anything that
we may make the world less favorable in
terms of living conditions for human
beings that's possible
but that would not destroy the planet
that might favor some other forms of
life for all we know maybe even bacteria
I don't know but we're not gonna destroy
the planet but we should we should
certainly take an active interest
and things that can make our environment
for humans better and and we have
undoubtedly done that over the last many
many years for the simple reason that
you know I don't know how many people
were on the planet ten thousand years
ago maybe ten million maybe a hundred
years ago there were two billion I don't
know
and today there's seven point six
billion so that's an additional five
point six billion people who have had
the opportunity to be alive that's
actually significant what's also
significant is that more and more people
are moving out of abject poverty into a
situation where they live longer they
have access to health care they have
access to education and so forth that's
not to say that there aren't inequities
there are lots of things that are unfair
but by and large there are far more
people living better today than at any
other time in history and one of the
things that we have today is this sort
of internet mp3 files the whole digital
world in that regard in India there are
400 million people on the Internet
and that is a phenomenal growth from
whatever was ten years ago less than 100
million four hundred million six hundred
and fifty million people in China are on
the internet typically they access the
internet via cell phones so that means
they also have cell phones which is
again revolutionary so that's and that's
just talking about India China that's
true in many other parts of the world in
Africa in the Middle East
wherever not to mention you know Europe
and North America Latin America and so
forth so we are increasingly connected
in this digital world now the reason I
bring this up in connection with
language learning is that in my last
video I spoke about how the Canadian
government is gonna sink sixteen million
dollars into some website to promote
the learning of the other official
language in Canada this morning I saw a
tweet by Michael McFaul who was the
former American ambassador to Russia and
who's a professor at Stanford University
very proud of himself and he tweets a
picture of the rain or sleet or snow
falling in Harvard and saying you know
come to Stanford because the weather is
so much better I visited Stanford once I
was in the bookstore they were selling
books for learning Italian Russian
French that cost like $200 of book there
is absolutely no need to spend that
amount of money for a language book we
live in a world where language learning
resources at the very least should be
abundantly available on the internet
they are abundantly available they
should be more abundantly available for
example I'm learning Arabic so I have in
the past bought Arabic learning
textbooks I think any textbook should
make available once you buy the book
twenty-five dollars whatever it is you
should have access to all of that text
in digital format and mp3 files for
download even if you charge me for it it
doesn't matter III I have these books I
can't put them in the link so that I can
look up words in many cases I don't have
the audio I have to send away for a CD
and they'll send me the CD I mean I want
the CD because it may have too much
English on it which is the case with
some of the CDs that I bought but what I
would like to have and the same is true
for a CML I have this s email text book
with audio but what I want is the
digital text so that I can import it
into link save the words and phrases
review them in my flashcards in my
different activities such as I'm now
doing with our mini stories why is this
stuff not available in digital format
and I've seen this many times and and
you know I think
you know Canadian government says they
want to promote bilingualism in Canada
they put God knows how much money into
our national broadcaster here it's got
to be a billion dollars everything that
the CBC and radio-canada put up their
programs on everything but a lot of it
should be available for download audio
and text audio and text it's it's so
useful for language learners to be able
to access just content we don't need
complicated
we don't need necessarily tutors great
to have a tutor but we don't need the
tutor because there are also grammar
resources available digitally but and
there are so many good examples of
places where they have done this when I
was studying check the check Radio
Chesky Rose class they had this
phenomenal series on the history call it
the Czech lands phenomenal beautifully
done
audio and text transcripts still
available told teachers Communiversity
you can download it alright they had
Yocto video which was you know political
discussion i didn't sympathize with a
lot of the sort of political views that
were more of a say on the leftist side
of things doesn't matter
it's for the language the same is true
of you know a chemistry and in russia
which many russians complain that it's
NT putin it's a you know it's a american
plot in which of course it isn't because
it's owned by Gazprom and it serves a
specific role within a you know Russian
media strategy and and in any case there
are many different opinions available
there but it doesn't matter what matters
is that there is audio and transcript so
you can download the audio you can
download the transcript and you can
learn from it and that's what in Canada
they should do if they want to help
people learn the other language get the
CBC into the digital age so that we can
access this material to learn languages
there are lots of podcasts with north
script I would like to see a world where
there's just more and more content made
available to people in that regard we
have been producing our many stories I
paid someone to produce these 60 stories
in English we've been first of all
having volunteers translate them and
record them and now for some languages
where we didn't get volunteers like
Arabic for example and not with Farsi we
are paying this stuff is available free
to anyone you just go to link and you
can just download it and listen to it
read audio and transcript as usual in
that regard we would like to get some
volunteers for Danish Norwegian and
Swedish people are asking for them I
don't really want to spend a lot of
money to do that because it's not as
important say a group of languages I say
Arabic but if there's any people out
there who want to help us I would very
much appreciate their help so to
summarize we live in the digital age
there are tremendous advantages
particularly from the perspective of a
language learner and we should encourage
people to create more content with audio
and transcript available for download
one of the most common questions I get
here and elsewhere is where can I find
audio with transcript content in
language X so we should maybe all push
for that so that we get more of that so
that textbook publishers make this
available once you have bought their
book some way that protects you know
their obviously their rights get
newspapers to provide audio get and
there is some of that there is audio
tech out there as for example there's a
new magazine that I subscribe to in the
Czech Republic which also provides audio
respect I think it is so there are
companies doing that I think The
Economist magazine out of England does
the Briton does the same and governments
government government broadcasters help
the world learn languages because in the
digital age we should all be learning
more languages all right a bit of a
meandering rent but I look forward to
your comments bye for now
[Music]